next this week's encore booknotes
presentation features Michael Patrick
McDonald author of the book All Souls a
family story from Southie in this
hour-long conversation he talks about
growing up in South Boston's Old Colony
project and losing four of his siblings
to the drug and violence culture of the
neighborhood this book notes originally
aired in December of last year Michael
Patrick McDonald what is your book all
souls about it's a story of growing up
in South Boston in the old colony
housing project it's my family story
growing up in a neighborhood where there
were three large housing projects mostly
populated by Irish American families a
lot of single-parent female-headed
households and it's a story of growing
up basically in a ghetto but what's
different about it is that it's not your
usual American picture of of ghetto most
of the residents are white it's a
neighborhood that US News and World
Report found to have had the highest
concentration of poor whites in America
in 1994 issue of the US News and World
Report and all of the issues around
poverty crime drugs and so forth that we
experienced growing up in the
neighborhood were issues that we weren't
really to talk about and for a number of
reasons one was the tendency for denial
perhaps calls for cultural reasons
mostly Irish American neighborhood but
also because of organized crimes control
of the neighborhood and suppression of
the truth by organized crime on the
cover of your book and I'm opening it to
it you know on the one side here it's
just rid of the cover I had to open the
whole book to show it there are six kids
here how many of these are still alive
of those four of those kids arrived who
are they those are the first six out of
eleven children we had eleven all
together enough family my mother lost
four children in all the first on the
far left is my oldest brother Davey
who
killed himself he jumped off a roof
in the housing project we grew up in at
the age of 24 and died the next brother
is John who was who got out so to speak
got out of the the neighborhood made it
out of old colony project went to Tufts
University became a lieutenant in the
Navy SEALs the next one is Joe who went
into the Air Force and who eventually
ended up moving out to Colorado and
helping my mother flee from the
neighborhood and got her out of ammo
colony project finally a few years back
in the early 90s and the next one is my
sister Mary who's a nurse in the
operating room at the Boston City
Hospital she also got out so to speak
and the next person is my brother
Frankie who was a four times Golden
Glove champion boxer Frankie's dead at
the age of 23 he got involved in an
armored car heist he was it was the
first time he got involved in anything
like that and the last time and he was
brought into that by older more
experienced gangsters who used him for
his youth and strength to kind of get
the job done that they needed to get
done who's the baby the next one is
Kathy who went off a roof
and in the housing project also she's
brain damaged after being pushed off the
roof in a fight over drugs and then not
pictured in and that is my brother Kevin
who was found hanging outside of his
prison cell in bridgewater Hospital in
Massachusetts which may have been
suicide may have been murder but it was
a suspicious death so how many children
did your mother have eleven but as are
seven of us alive her life I always I
always go with the original number
because that's still there's still all
her children and how many fathers were
there out of those 11 kids on the first
nine children
the first eight children up to Patrick
who was a baby that died before I was
born first eight children were by her
first husband Dave McDonald who she was
married to through many years of a
and who's she stuck with despite the
abuse and womanizing and so forth by him
because she was Catholic Irish daughter
of Irish immigrants and was even told by
her local priest that she should make
the best of it
despite the beatings and so forth
finally when the baby died she she left
him and took the kids and and was
raising the kids in a housing project a
mostly black housing project on the
South Boston Dorchester waterfront I was
born by another father and who my mother
wasn't married to and then my two
younger brothers were born 10 years
after me to it a third father but
growing up in a colony we we like a lot
of the families there had fled mostly
black housing project and it was a
neighborhood where people just had this
incredible sense of place incredible
sense of community incredible sense of
common struggle so to speak and part of
that was because most of us came from
similar families a lot of single-parent
female-headed households where is David
McDonald the father of whatever what was
it eight of those children yeah he died
a few years back I don't even in the
book I don't even get so far as what
what became of of different people's
fathers because they kind of become
irrelevant after a while and to this
story let me just home in on one of the
stories your sister Kathy mm-hmm who is
where is she today she's living in
Colorado with my family my mother moved
out there and she's brain damaged and
partially paralyzed she was in a coma
for five months and really miraculously
lived but when she came out of the coma
her brain started to deteriorate and
she's kind of degenerated into almost
like schizophrenia where she's half the
time in a fantasy world and how did she
injure herself but he at a young age
Kathy got involved in the streets really
of all of all my family members my
sister Kathy and my brother Kevin were
the most involved in the streets and
Kevin as I said died young he was found
hanging outside of his prison cell and
Kathy went off a roof at the age of 18
after a fight over drugs with a
boyfriend she was jumped off the roof
she was pushed yeah humorless well I was
a it was a fight with a boyfriend where
she probably wasn't intentional like I'm
gonna you know do UN type of situation
but it was a fight over drugs and there
was a struggle and she went off the roof
you know so it was a cold winter night
and Kathy at the time was pretty high
herself on what kind of drugs pills she
had she'd gotten involved in angel dust
at a young age in the 1970s the
neighborhood became controlled by local
drug lord named James Whitey Bulger
who's pretty well-known because he was
the Senate president's brother bill
Bulger yeah and he took control of the
neighborhood in the 70s probably around
the same time that busing took place
around 1974 is when he really started to
get a stronger hold in the neighborhood
and when the neighborhood was under such
siege because of busing a sense of siege
and and people were in so much pain a
lot of people jumped into the arms of
people like him and other gangsters and
politicians for a sense of safety
ironically we recently found out that
through all those years of whitey
Bulger's drug dealing in the
neighborhood and poisoning of belleau
children that he was actually protected
by the FBI because he was an informant
for the FBI I'm informing on the Italian
mafia across town and his relationship
with the FBI began about 1974 sameera
the busing happened and the neighborhood
was really kind of in a state of
upheaval from desegregation back to
Kathy person first of all how old are
you today I'm 33 how old is Cathy cat
he's 37 and she she her injury was in
what when she was 18 and 19 and the
range age of all the kids how's your
youngest brother and sister right now my
youngest brother Stevie is 22 now yeah
and your oldest the oldest Davey would
be 43 well most of us are about a year
to a pot and my there's a 10 year
difference between me and my two younger
brothers the part of your look I don't
know if you can talk it because it's
it's complicated but I want to go back
to the moment when Kathy was in the
hospital because after when Kathy's in
the hospital you began the list I've got
the names written down here yeah I mean
I don't know how long this test is but
we'll give where were the circumstances
in the hospital I knew it was going on I
started to sense what was going on in
the neighborhood at a young age started
to try to always make sense of the chaos
I was seen in the streets and started to
maybe separate myself from the chaos a
little bit and that was part of my own
survival instincts I think so when she
was in the hospital and a coma
who five months yeah was she in the
hospital at whole time yes she was and
you were about 14 yeah most of time
intensive care and she was lots of times
on the danger list and lots of times
they didn't know if she'd live or die
and most days I was there at her bedside
while she was in the coma but you
started the list and I've written the
names down here Karen there was a local
nurse that that was from Oconee a girl
that everyone loved dearly in the
neighborhood who was a nurse in the City
Hospital she used to come by and give my
mother updates about Kathy
but what happened it she was she was
murdered by her boyfriend and that was a
real shock to people in the neighborhood
it was it was while writing that chapter
I mean Karen was the nurse that was in
the hospital but it was while writing
that chapter
remembering Kathy's friends that came in
to see her in the coma that I started to
realize that all these people that I was
writing about are now dead so I started
jumping around a bit and and wrote about
her friends visiting her but then would
have to tell the reader that you know
within two years he was found killed
well let me go through someone though
because it helps to tell the whole story
whereas Karen was strangled by her
boyfriend yeah why all right who knows I
mean that's you know there's never any
answers that was domestic violence and
Timmy Bolton yeah he was Cathy's
boyfriend who was murdered outside of a
local pub in front of about 200 people
and nobody spoke nobody saw anything
when this was probably a couple of years
after I about three years after I saw
him visiting Kathy and the coma in 1984
which was a pretty bad year 1985
actually yeah it was marked as murder
that's the person that allegedly
murdered him according to people in the
neighborhood but a few years ago he too
was murdered also in front of a lot of
witnesses none of whom would speak did
he come to visit your sister he was
someone that I mentioned in relation to
Timmy's death but he wasn't really he
was kind of part of the same generation
but he wasn't in the hospital it was
Julie meanie
that was one of Kathy's best friends and
she was a young girl who like Kathy was
getting into the angel dust that was
being brought into the neighborhood by
Whitey Bulger and and as a teenager the
two of them hung out and got into
trouble together and she ended up dead
kind of a mysterious desk death she it
was probably a suicide but there was
kind of a neighborhood myth around her
death maybe I don't know whether it's a
myth or not but supposedly she walked
into the ocean and didn't come out so
and at what time in her life did she do
that she was a teenager well she was
probably just a few years older than
Kathy was when she was in the coma so
most of the deaths around that time
throughout the 80s
and two people in their late teens early
20s who was Frank McGurk he was a friend
of Cathy's as well that was murdered in
a hallway in the in the housing project
a good friend of Cathy's he was actually
someone who sold angel dust and and was
doing it himself and he's someone my
mother blamed for Kathy's involvement in
that at the time but anyway when he was
murdered what I write about in the book
is kind of the neighborhood attitude
when something like that would happen
something so visible something right in
our hallways in the housing project that
the neighborhood attitude would be
almost like good riddance because you
know he was no good anyway you know but
was he that visit your sister yeah but
um that kind of attitude about a lot of
the deaths in the neighborhood was a way
for people who hadn't been through those
things to feel safe like this stuff
isn't gonna happen to me this stuff only
happens to bad people who was Tommy
Dooley um he was a friend of Kathy's as
well that was murdered at the local bar
Kelly's cork and bull just outside the
bar at what point in this whole story um
he was murdered in 85 I believe and he
again a lot of witnesses nobody would
speak nobody saw anything
and was dead even LeClair he was a
another friend of mine actually someone
I hung out with at a young age and he
was run over and that car yeah it was at
an accident it was a lot of people said
it was intentional but you know there's
and a lot of people witnessed it and of
course you know why would somebody want
to run over I don't know I mean a lot of
things in South Boston it's just you
know there's all this that you know you
see someone one day back then anyway
this isn't the case now I mean now it's
more around heroin
back then it was angel Dustin and into
the 80s cocaine put a lot of things will
happen to people where you know here
today gone tomorrow and
and people would justify those violent
deaths by again by by making like the
person somehow deserved it which isn't
necessarily the case so that's why I
don't even care to get into what he was
doing or what anybody was involved in
because it's in the end there's no way
you can justify those to this type of
bloodbath that happened in the
neighborhood that was brought on by
Whitey Bulger the neighborhood drug lord
who was okey O'Connor oh he was a good
friend of Kevin's that your brother yeah
and and my brother Frankie as well
someone that my mother loved dearly he
was a a good kid that ended up like a
lot of people of that generation hanging
himself was he did he visit your sister
he was oh yeah he was very good about
visiting my sister in the coma
it was it was just amazing that you know
going through these people and
remembering them visiting her and
remembering them for their loyalties to
her but also realizing that so many of
those people that that that you know had
such a good side to them also possibly
had a shady side or you know things that
would lead to who's Brian Bilodeau
he was a kid that my mother taught in an
alternative school for juvenile
delinquents and he became friends with
the family and he at a young age even
while he was at this school he tried to
rob someone's house in the D Street
housing project the next housing project
over from us and he was shot and
paralyzed so most of the years that I
knew Brian he was in a wheelchair at
first with with his legs and and he
eventually lost both of his legs from
disease and and gangrene I believe but
in the end he overdosed on heroin and
more in recent years actually but he's
another person that would come in to see
Kathy and was wheel it wheeled in all
the way from South Boston he was kind of
like a neighborhood character we had a
lot of them a lot of neighborhood
characters you know and finally on the
list Michael Dizz oh oh he was
from the the zocalo family he was a
young person that was my mother always
remembers for having just gone to his
graduation one week and then within a
few weeks he was he was murdered his his
murder was an uncle and nephew were
murdered together
[Music]
the nephew ran up to try to see what was
happening to his uncle when he heard the
gunshots and he was shot as well now all
these people visited your sister over
that five months yeah yeah yeah a lot of
a lot of other people did as well who
who also ended up dead but it was there
was only so much I could give the reader
in terms of the bloodbath how do you
handle all this for me they it's it's
been a commitment to healing through
activism through talking about it since
1990 1990s when I got involved as an
activist and a community organizer
citywide mostly working in black and
Latino neighborhoods because that's
where these people that's where these
issues were being talked about and
people like my brothers were being
remembered and and people like my family
were talking about what they had been
through so I found it easier to talk
about these things into work and black
and Latino neighborhoods because of my
neighborhood
you didn't really talk about these
things these things didn't exist those
things are black things those are things
that don't exist in our neighborhood
those things don't happen to us we're
white we're Irish were proud and and
kind of whitey bulger kind of kept that
potty line going even though you know we
we all saw the the the number of wakes
and and the number of young lives
snuffed out
where's Whitey Bulger today he's on the
run the FBI a few years ago you know
have this well he there was an an
indictment on him for drug dealing and
murder and
caring and he was actually they say he
was warned by one of his associates in
the FBI that an arrest was pending and
he fled and some people believe he's
being protected by the FBI still hidden
by certain agents because if he ever
came out of hiding he would give up a
lot of secrets about the way that the
government works with gangster
informants where's his brother William
Bulger he's the president of the
University of Massachusetts now whitey
I think what's interesting about his
involvement with the FBI is that to me
anyway is that he it's not just you know
working with a low-level criminal to get
information about higher more dangerous
criminals he was a drug lord and he was
a mafia dawn he was the head of the
Irish mafia and Boston and crunk
controlled a lot of the drug trade in
Boston and this is who agents of the FBI
worked with for the big four what they
thought was the bigger prize that the
Italian mafia across town but of course
as I've said nobody took into
consideration the number of our young
lives that were being snuffed out by
drugs and violence in those years you
have some photos inside the two top
photos here on this page who's in them
the first one is my mother surrounded by
her first four children behind her is
Devi the oldest the young girl at her
side is Mary on her lap is Jo Mary and
Joe are twins
and the next one is Johnny she's
pregnant with her fifth child she's 25
years old in that picture I found out
with the gloves on that's my brother
Frankie and that in the first picture my
mother's actually pregnant with Frankie
and the second picture is my brother
Frankie four times Golden Gloves
champion boxer and dead at the age of 23
and an armored cast where's your mom now
my mother fled to Colorado
and she's living a much quieter life out
there and in a pretty functional
community that's for one thing so it's R
economically diverse and and you know
not a ghetto so and and there's a lot of
space and a lot of fresh air and so
forth she's raising my niece my sister
Kathy went off the roof had a daughter
named Maria and my mother's raising her
and my little brothers spent all their
teenage years out in Colorado and as a
result are completely different people
leading completely different lives than
they might have fled had they stayed in
South Boston my mother one out there to
give their give them a better life and
to give my niece Maria a better life my
little brothers asked about a lot of the
friends some of their best friends
growing up in South Boston and a good
number of them are in jail or in trouble
of a racial violence the housing
projects were recently integrated and
there's been a lot of racial violence
around the integration he's your mother
married no duties where she lives single
and doesn't even date
the people where she lives now know this
story oh yeah well they do now
definitely what did she think of you
writing this um she's she's happy about
it she's committed to to the truth she
knows what's in it she can't read it but
she knows what's in it and she
why can't she read it it's too painful
for her and she you know we all all
survivors have their own techniques and
and what they can and can't deal with
and what they can you know what levels
of doses they can swallow of their
traumas
because I'm only writing from the
perspective of a brother we've lost who
has lost so many siblings to violence
and crime and in suicide and but I could
never and I hope I never know what it's
like I could I just can't imagine what
it's like to be the mother who's lost
one child never mind that many because
why I you know whatever she needs to do
if she she can't read this right now and
take it all and kind of in one sitting
then I respect that why did you decide
to write the book I wrote it as an
extension of the the healing process
they as I said I got involved as an
activist in those neighborhoods
eventually brought it back to South
Boston in 1994 when I moved back to
South Boston took a lot of the
experiences I had learned in the black
and Latino neighborhoods about community
organizing and about telling the truth
back to South Boston and that just led
to me eventually wanting to go even
deeper into my story because a lot of
times I used my family's story as an
activist to raise awareness to do work
against gun violence to do work on youth
development in the communities I would
use stories from my family lots of times
so so I knew this was I wanted to tell
this story and go deeper into it by
writing this book and so for me it's
been an extension of the healing process
and was it was something I you know that
the the actual results were not what I
expected I mean I just didn't expect it
to be this to feel so good to have
written this so we've told the story and
to go deep into the truth about my
family and in my community what kind of
education do you have I went to
University of Massachusetts and
graduated from there but in high school
I was I was going to Boston Latin School
which is the the cities exam school and
I it's a public school but it's
considered you know an elite school kind
of um I was going to visit my sister a
lot when she was in the coma actually
everyday and as a result was missing a
lot of school I was just I was playing
hooky to go be at her bedside and talked
to her and you know I didn't know what I
thought I could do maybe help bring her
out of the coma by exercising her brain
and would just talk to her about you
know people friends were asking for and
so forth people that were coming in that
day and when I finally went back to
Latin
school of course they they said that I
would probably need to be kept back the
following year and all my life I'd
always gotten straight A's and I
couldn't deal with the idea of being
kept back so Latin school allowed you to
get promoted if you would leave the
school and go to a regular Boston public
school so I went with that and when I
found out that they were assigning me to
Roxbury a neighborhood across town that
was black neighborhood to probably be
the only white student in the classroom
because a lot of after bus and a lot of
people of my generation if they were
assigned to schools across town in the
black neighborhoods they ended up
dropping out and I did the same thing
and I I was you know really probably one
of the more liberal leaning people in my
neighborhood but even even I didn't want
to be the guinea pig you know especially
not just being the only white kid in the
class but to be from Southie in one of
those neighborhoods after the amount of
racial violence that erupted in South
Boston as a result of busing and the
label that we got and we still have to
this day as you know a bastion of white
racism in America a label that I think
is unfairly applied to the neighborhood
without much consideration for and a
distraction really from a lot of the
other the real social problems in the
neighborhood around poverty and so forth
a convenient distraction but um lots of
times we'd have to outside the
neighborhood say that the we were from
somewhere else most people when you
leave the neighborhood don't want you
know we didn't want to say that we were
from Southie whether it was in a
racially mixed area that we were going
to or in a more cosmopolitan upper
middle-class white liberal area we would
never say we're from South Boston
because to do so would be to uh you know
to be the enemy go back to your sister
Kathy that five-month period when went
through all those people who died what's
the story about her coming - after being
in a coma for five months
your grandfather yeah one of the people
I would meet in the hospital was my
grandfather he was from County Kerry and
from a small town called Castle Island
and he and my mother had kind of a
strange relationship
mostly hostile but they're actually very
close and he he didn't wasn't really
that involved with my family my mother
was kind of like the black sheep of the
family after a while she ended up in the
project and so forth and and she was
divorced and then of course having me
she had me out of wedlock which was you
know the ultimate so there was there was
a little bit of a you know alienation
between the two of them but it's when
Kathy was in the coma that my
grandfather really started to try to
come around and to try to be more
involved and he was kind of he had
become kind of a fanatic about some of
the apparitions by the Blessed Mother
around the world and Fatima and Lourdes
and so forth and he had he had been to
those places many times and brought back
holy water and I met him in the hospital
one day when he pulled out of his his
big baggy trousers of this big jug of
holy water and instead of splash it all
over Kathy and and the nurses started
coming in the room trying to stop him
because they were afraid she'd be get
she'd get pneumonia and he was swearing
at them and cursing and throwing the
holy water on her and and screaming into
Kathy's ear too you know if she can hear
him raise her arm and and she did you
know he said Kathy if you can hear me
now raise your arm and she did raise
from and it's then that she started to
wake up and I write about that in the
book because for me it was kind of a
funny story at the time to see him you
know with tears in his eyes really for
his daughter and for his granddaughter
and and the amount of passion he put
into that ritual of spread of the holy
water it was was kind of a need for him
to be closer to his his daughter and to
her daughter his daughters kids but
myself on the bus going home afterwards
with him I just had a really good
feeling and he was talking about how he
had a good feeling about Kathy that she
was gonna wake up from the coma and I
talk in the book about how I had a good
feeling but it was more
because I realized how close my
grandfather really was to my mother and
how much he cared about her even though
he couldn't say that kind of thing and a
lot of the dynamics between the two of
them are kind of typical stories from
Irish families really I think there's a
lot of difficulty with affection in
Irish families and and there's a lot of
affection expressed through hostility
sometimes and and that's something that
you see throughout a lot of Irish
literature I think there are a lot of
terms that I wrote down just to get a
definition from you what's an Irish
whisper oh that's that's basically when
someone's telling a secret but they're
screaming it from across the street it's
not much of a secret at all but um I
talk about that because I kind of had a
big mouth I was a kid and I'd be talking
about things like Whitey Bulger and
gangsters you know really loud and and
my brother Kevin would be more careful
and tell me to shut my mouth and keep it
down and when I was older my little
brother's used to refer to the the
liquor store at the end of our street as
the Irish mafia store and my little
brother Shamus would scream it up to the
window could just you know ask him for
50 cents to go to the Irish mafia store
to get some candy and so forth the Irish
mafia store is where Whitey Bulger ran
his drug trade and in South Boston it
was right at the edge of the Old Colony
housing project probably the most
lucrative place you could possibly set
up the drug trade you know in the edge
of a housing project very wisely set up
there and I referred to sheamus's young
things like that up to the window is as
an Irish whisperer as well you know who
was scoochie yeah she was local klepto
maniac who went door-to-door with
shopping bags selling stolen goods to a
lot of the families including my mother
and clothes for the kids and so forth
I'm at a big discount and she was just
someone she was a neighbourhood person
that was just getting by you know she
she's someone that I write about with I
I think a lot of sympathy because she
was she was you know a lot of this book
is to me one of the things that came out
and writing it was I started to realize
the you know just the the feminization
of poverty regardless of race I had
never thought about that before but a
lot of these people than writing about a
woman and people like scoochie a woman
doing what they had to do to survive I
mean there are bad guys at the at the at
the top of a lot of the drug and
criminal activity in the neighborhood
but those are real higher up bad guys
that have makin literally millions of
dollars and but I I really you know
people like scoochie and other people
involved in petty crime or or drugs I
have a lot of sympathy for or as victims
you know who played into the victim role
themselves but but nonetheless war
victims will poor people that were used
and manipulated who were the project
rats project rat was just a term that
you would use in the neighborhood for
anybody from the project so myself I was
I would be called a project rat by
somebody from outside the project there
were kind of these these tears in the
neighborhood there was the the end of
town called City point that was up hill
and the kids from up there
protected their turf like the kids who
know colony protected their turf but the
but City point was more working class to
middle class part of the neighborhood
very nice section of the neighborhood
not part of those lower end census
tracts that have the highest
concentration of white poverty in
America these are more families with
fathers usually working-class fathers in
construction and so forth but we thought
they were rich who were white [ __ ]
basically the US again why would you use
that term that was a term that people
you know a few times as a kid people
referred to people from my project
referred to the kids in D Street
as kind of a lower group and and I it
was explained to me once that they were
white [ __ ] and I was really confused
about the meaning of that it was when we
first moved into the neighborhood and I
was trying to figure out what all this
meant and then I found out that I was
one when I would go up to City point to
what I thought was the rich end of town
which was the actually the middle-class
end of town and I'd be chased back to
the project called called that that
happened once but it was just it was
very confusing and it was this term that
I was trying to make sense of even to
hear that you know to hit the n-word at
all because you know we had come from
Columbia Point which was an all-black
housing project and then we lived in a
racially mixed neighborhood of Jamaica
Plain so I was trying to as I said in
the book make sense of this hierarchy of
[ __ ] and it was a lesson
so quite a lesson to learn at a young
age about how people always have someone
that's lesser than them no matter how
low you are on the totem pole there's
always someone that's lower than you
what do you do for the living now right
now I am I'm an activist in Boston been
taken some time off to write the book
and I'm planning to actually do more
writing more full-time writing and I've
been involved in community organizing
efforts in Northern Ireland this summer
I was up on the gabbai he rode during
the marching season when the Orange
Order marches through Catholic
neighborhoods and basically terrorizes
the community and influenced their
bigotry anty anty Irish Catholic bigotry
and it was really interesting being up
there I was there for for half the
summer and I was staying in a housing
estate which is a fancy word for a
housing project over there and the
neighbors over there were people who
looked exactly like my neighbors growing
up an O'Conner project they all had
these Irish faces and and and even
dressed like a lot of my old neighbors
and and smoked as much as my neighbors
where you know a lot of people in
South Boston smoke and same thing in
Ireland and especially up there in a
trouble place like the gabbai he wrote
the difference was that these people
looked so much like my old neighbors but
they knew as poor people and working
class people they knew where they stood
in the world and they knew where they
stood so it's our economically as well
as racially because the situation up
there is almost like the racial
situation over here except it's it's
ethnic and they all would speak in this
incredibly progressive language about
their solidarity with black South
Africans above their solidarity with
African Americans and how they were so
influenced by the civil rights movement
in America and that was shocked because
these people looked like my neighbors
and of course my neighbors are Irish
American proud to be Irish all about the
Shamrock and Ireland and so forth but
don't really know a lot about the
culture and history of Ireland and don't
really know about people in Ireland's
awareness around around racial issues
they didn't want to hear about Irish
Americans they wanted to hear about
African Americans up there what are the
personal traits of someone who's Irish
the personal traits in any way when you
say somebody's oh that's an Irish thing
what does that mean well give me the
what would Irish people do that other
people don't do well I don't know if
they you know what they do that other
people don't do but I know there are
some things that I've identified as
definitely very Irish like I pointed out
my my mother and her father's
relationship I think that they they had
a very Irish father-daughter
relationship and one of the biggest
things for me that comes through in the
book is the the culture of denial which
is something that you you see in Ireland
as well as America probably even more so
in America now because see what happens
that what happened I think is that later
generate that you know in in South
Boston you have people who are third and
fourth generation Irish American and
they're carrying on a lot of the traits
that their grandparents and
great-grandparents came to this country
with you know
a place like South Boston was created as
an enclave as an Irish Enclave to feel
safety from the wasp ascendancy in in
downtown Boston and so forth then and
things like that don't have as much
relevance in the modern world as they
did at one time but people in that
neighborhood is still carrying out those
things and and there are a lot of there
are a lot of things like that that I
would say that you know fourth
generation Irish Americans are still
living that Irish people themselves may
have moved on from Ireland is this
incredibly progressive country where
people you know the economy is moving
forward the people have entered the age
of technology they were the way ahead of
us on that and people's attitudes a lot
of the Irish immigrants to move into the
neighborhood now are these young people
you know with you know pierced eyebrows
and shaved heads and our own kids are
much more conservative and all about
being you know conforming to the Southie
the Southie look and so forth you know
which is more of an old-fashioned Irish
immigrant look sometimes with a Scalli
cap and so forth so it's it's funny
Ireland's kind of moved well beyond
South Boston into the modern age you
often refer to the fact that your mother
like to wear spiked heels red hair like
you yeah and you kept referring the fact
she was a good-looking woman mm-hmm
she's still good-looking yeah she's 65
and she looks you know probably about 15
years younger but she was always known
for a look my mother's whole personality
her appearance and so forth I think is
what keeps his book from being a really
tragic book because she she kind of
lifts the story up whenever it's getting
really tragic she's the one to lift it
up and in real life that was her role in
the family as well and for other people
who was surviving horrible atrocities in
the neighborhood she served that role as
well she would lift them up and she
would she would inspire them to keep
going and to keep moving on it was her
reaction I mean you talk about the bow
but I don't know if you can describe it
when Devi died her Frankie died or all
that I mean how did she handle all those
times she would it was different every
time
and you see how when I I witnessed my
mother crying my earliest memory that I
talk about in the book is witnessing my
mother crying for the loss of her baby
Patrick Michael who basically i replaced
i was born a year later and you're a
Michael Patrick hmm and he was a baby
that was brought to the emergency room
at the Children's Hospital and was
denied admittance because this was one
year before Medicaid and it was a
welfare baby and they had a system
whereby they would they would have their
quota of charity cases and they had
filled their their quarter of charity
cases for the night and they also didn't
think that that Patrick was an emergency
situation he died that night of
pneumonia he was sent home sent home to
die which basically wouldn't have
happened if he weren't a welfare baby
with no insurance I was born in the
shadow of that and so I I was you know I
was able to witness my mother and some
of her most intimate morning before the
baby that had died and I also saw how
she dealt with Davey's suicide when he
died how'd he die
when he committed suicide he jumped off
the roof again why though he was
schizophrenic Davey he had had a
breakdown at the age of 14 probably he
had he had witnessed a lot of bad things
in the family you know for his father
he'd experienced abuse from his father
you know beatings and so forth who saw
him is the oldest jump off at I I was I
was home that day you saw that yeah I
saw it happen I saw him on the ground
covered in blood I was 13 years old I
was minding my two little brothers
Seamus and Stevie and my brother Frankie
who died only a few years later was at
the kitchen table eating dinner and
there were all these screams out front
and pounding on the door and neighbor
was screaming that Davey jumped or
actually they said he fell we realized
he jumped I mean he had been suffering
from mental illness for a long time
and but that I'll never forget that day
and I write about that that was one of
the most painful things for me to write
about in the book and again something
that had felt so good after I wrote it
and wrote the details of his
blood-stained flannel shirt that he was
wearing and and my descriptions of my
memories of Davey how I how I after his
funeral sat and thought about him and
and what his life was like as a mentally
ill person and and as a person who was
sent out of the mental hospitals during
deinstitutionalization into this housing
project that was probably more insane
than than the mental hospital they had
come from and he went from one Asylum to
this you know bigger asylum in the midst
of busing chaos and the riots and the
streets and and SWAT teams on the
rooftops in the National Guard
everywhere and and helicopters hovering
above our windows it was a crazy world
during busing what year were you born I
was born in 1966 and what year did the
busing start in 1974 who was Louise Day
Hicks Louise Day Hicks was a local
Councilwoman she was on the School
Committee and she's one of the reasons
that busing happened in the first place
she was considered a defender of the
neighborhood by local people because she
was you know standing up to the Liberals
and so forth but really when she was on
the school committee along with a man
named John Kerrigan they were the reason
that busing was forced upon the city in
the first place because they would not
admit inequality the inequality of the
school system and the the level of
deterioration happening in the black
inner-city schools and they wouldn't MIT
to that and they wouldn't admit to de
facto segregation in the city and
eventually they they were sued
and that's when the the federal judge
stepped in and ordered forced busing
where is she today she's she's an older
woman she lives in City Point she's from
city the city point end of town of
course the nicer end of town her her
father was a judge she probably grew up
more upper-middle class than I did here
busing today in your area just this fall
the school system has gone back as a
result of another lawsuit brought on by
parents who want more choice the school
system has ended its previous school
assignment plan
did it work race-based it's gonna
actually be implemented starting no
busing yeah
busing didn't you know it might have
worked for some things it it some people
just had the agenda of black kids going
to South Boston high but I don't think
people really knew that you know how bad
at school South Boston High was at the
time only 10% of the people from South
Boston high were going on to college I
mean so rather than developing a plan
where we're both black inner-city kids
and white and a city poor kids would
gain access to to better school systems
perhaps in the suburbs you know of
course they took the poorest white
neighborhood poorest black neighborhood
and set them on each other and of course
it failed and I sometimes wonder if
these things aren't designed to fail
because that that was either incredibly
dumb or incredibly brilliant
setting up those two neighborhoods where
do you live now I live in South Boston
Southie yep why did you go batty I moved
back in 1994 because I was drawn back to
the neighborhood I've always felt a draw
because of my memories of my brothers
and my families when my family left
South Boston in 1991 and went to
Colorado I felt uprooted I left the
neighborhood moved to another
neighborhood always missed Southie would
wander through South East - kind of
just kind of find my family spirit on my
brothers spirits and I felt like it was
there and I was I was drawn to move back
there after the I gave a tour to a
reporter from US News and World Report
who was writing this story about what he
called the white underclass because
South Boston was being called the white
underclass capital of America
and when I gave him that tour I realized
how much I missed the neighborhood
despite that I was pointing out spots in
the neighborhood where some of the worst
atrocities happened I just kind of
abruptly told him you know I really
missed this place and I've always had
that love/hate thing with the
neighborhood and was just had to go back
there and when I went back there I found
out why I went back there I went back
there to do some community organizing
and to write this book and I didn't
realize that until now picture there of
the most where the most kids are located
what's that picture oh that's a picture
of a bunch of kids from the project
visiting my brother John who is the the
guy in the and that with the afro and
the plaid pants he was up at Tufts
University he was the one on the family
making it out and we would all come up
and invade his new world and of course
his fellow students would find out where
he really comes from where's John Wood
today he's in South America what's he do
he he's built he's retired from the Navy
SEALs but he's working on building a
development he does labor labor work you
know what's the story of Stevie my
little brother Stevie in 1990 was
falsely accused of murder and what were
the circumstances his best friend was
who was 13 years old died from a gunshot
wound to the head and Stephen found him
dying and I got very involved in his
case once the police once I started to
realize what the police were doing once
I found out that the police had
falsified his call to 9-1-1
and so forth he found his friend ina and
called 9-1-1 where was his friend his
friend was in the house he had he had
fallen under a bamboo chair large bamboo
swivel chair this was one of the hardest
tragedies for me to live through really
it was it was definitely the worst
because it was something happening to a
younger brother and because of the the
the horrible tragedy of this 13 year old
boy's death
in that apartment and and what year was
this 90 yeah and he was your brother
though was convicted yeah he was
convicted and and when I really saw the
level of police misconduct and police
abuse in this case falsification of
evidence and so forth and when he called
9-1-1
well they submitted a transcript of his
called tonight one one and it had him
yeah the police submitted this as
evidence that there was good there was
you know gonna go into court it had my
little brother's saying twice on this
sheet of paper which I have copies up to
this day I just shot my friend in the
head so I had my little brother calling
in and confessing to have shot his
friend when I first saw that I thought
maybe he did do it and maybe he blacked
it out or something and we ordered the
cassettes of his call tonight one one it
took about a month to get them but when
we heard that cassette there wasn't even
anything you could mistake for I just
shot my friend in the head so it was him
given his address screaming crying and
so forth but these the four detectives
at the center of that case were very
involved in a very high-profile racist
investigation in the city what's what we
call the Stewart case when a man called
Charles Stewart a white man from the
suburbs murdered his pregnant wife and
on the way from birthing classes and
when the police arrived Charles Stuart's
told the police that a black men had
carjacked them from the nearby black
housing project
and he'll and as a result the police and
the mayor completely tore that community
part people were brought dragged out of
the houses kids were stopped and
searched it was it became like a police
state in Mission Hill and witnesses were
coerced into giving false statements
about a local junkie named Willie
Bennett anyways it turned out that child
stewart had in fact shot his wife and
that the police were so quick to believe
this racial accusation anyway the cops
at the center of railroading this guy in
Mission Hill project well the same cops
involved in my little brother's case and
that's what got me to cross town to
cross neighborhood and cross race and
get involved with activists across town
on some of these issues whether they
were police community relations issues
to work on as an activist or the stuff
around gun violence how did you get the
conviction overturned it took us four
years to do that but my little brother
had been released from dys it's dys
other Department of Youth Services in
Massachusetts and they have they they
make the decision about how long a
person is to stay with them and they
when he was released his psychiatrist
there had to apologize to him for the
whole entire criminal justice system and
this is before his conviction was
overturned because the psychiatrist was
saying even you know even if I took you
and even if I believed that you were
guilty and that he shot your friend I
still don't know what you're doing here
and he said you know so many times you
see it on the news where two children
are playing with the gun and one shoots
the other and you see that there's no
prosecution that takes place lots of
times the victim's family is you know it
doesn't want to prosecution the same
year I saw that happen on the news and
in this case Stephen wasn't even guilty
I believe wholeheartedly but this
psychiatrist was saying that you know
even if I believe you're guilty I still
don't know why you you would drag
through this system as you were as a
child and he said you know
I have to believe that it has everything
to do with who you are and where you
come from who overturned the case it was
overturned by the state Supreme Court
and I was in a unanimous decision by
three judges based on the lawyers in the
the original trial lawyers incompetence
in relation to some of the obvious
police abuse and misconduct and
falsification of evidence where's Stevie
today he's in Colorado he's in college
he's along with my other brother Shamus
doing very well
they've good grade point averages and
they want to be lawyers so again I think
that's that's a theme that comes out a
lot in the book whether it's my mother
who's you know helping out some of the
mothers in the neighborhood who were
losing their children you know sharing
some of her strengths or myself getting
involved as an activist or my little
brothers wanted to be a lawyer I think a
common theme is this this survival
through action rather than medication or
therapy or whatever I think that's a big
issue that comes to around the book why
did you get in trouble all through these
years I didn't get in trouble because I
think at it because at a young age this
is something that I figured out while I
was writing the book at a young age I I
was able to kind of step outside of the
chaos with one foot even while keeping
another foot there I'm still from that
neighborhood I'm still from my family
but I was always able to be kind of to
see that world from from the outside and
to see the bigger picture so that I
wasn't trapped in it I never felt
trapped in it I never felt like my life
is gonna be determined by this that's a
common factor that you see in a lot of
what what teachers and and and
psychologists are calling resilience and
young people that's a common factor that
ability to step outside of any kind of
situation chaotic situation growing up
and to say that's not necessarily me
that's not going to determine Who I am
what's your long term goal um to keep
writing I love writing and I and I
really miss it during all this publicity
but I can't can't wait to get back to
writing I'd like to write more from
stories
from my life to maybe get deeper into
some pieces of the book and I'd also
like to write about other places where
that need this kind of truth-telling and
my only goals in general to tell the
truth and to help kids live I just want
kids to live that's that's really why
why I wrote the book is so this is the
cover of the book all souls is the title
and our guest has been Michael Patrick
McDonald the story of a family from
Southie thank you very much thanks a lot
Michael Patrick McDonald helped launch
Boston's gun buyback program and is the
founder of the South Boston vigil group
All Souls a family story from Southie
was recently released in paperback by
Ballantine Books and division of Random
House